in 2013
a 330 000 hamburger received worldwide
attention
why it was grown in a lab
researchers and entrepreneurs joined
forces to create
cultured meat an innovation that can
satisfy your taste buds
without the environmental or ethical
worries associated with traditional
animal agriculture
cultured meat which goes by many names
is real
meat that is produced by in vitro cell
cultures
first scientists obtain a muscle sample
from a live animal
next cells are extracted from the sample
and bathed in a nutrient-rich growth
medium
that allows them to proliferate
exponentially
given that the industry is relatively
new there are challenges cultured meat
must
tackle to become a staple on our dinner
plates
one obstacle is replicating the textures
and shapes
of animal grown meat to overcome this
scientists are experimenting with
growing meat on scaffolds
which encourage cells to form into
specific structures
another challenge is that growing
cultivated meat is relatively costly
but since the lab-grown burger's first
debut
expenses have fallen dramatically and
continue to do so
thanks to the dedication of researchers
and entrepreneurs
cultured meat would one day help be the
world's growing population
in more ethical and sustainable ways
[Music]
you